I think that question has been asked
about rights for all beings for example
back in sojourner truth's time and she
is a heroine of mine when she fought for
the rights of black people to be
emancipated she was jeered at the
buildings in which he was staying with
sometimes burned because people could
not imagine that here was not only a
black person but a black woman daring to
talk to what were then audiences of
white males about what a black person or
black woman or any individual wanted so
I believe that we have to look at it in
that context of it doesn't really matter
who it is it only matters what we do and
what we feel is just these lines maybe
at some point your interests would
converge or contradict the interest of
another human being you weigh it if a
dog attacks you you're going to have to
take some action against that dog but
you don't necessarily have to shoot the
dog in the head you don't have to
torture the dog you can take aversive
action if you can't maybe you do have to
shoot the dog in the head if a mugger is
coming at you you shouldn't you know
kill them hopefully you'll be able to
take an aversive action or do the least
damage that you need to do but you might
have to so it really depends on the
circumstance it's not really a question
of species it's a question of how can
you do the least harm how can you avoid
doing the most home